protesters on the march in tunis after
the announcement by president kaisai to
dissolve tunisia's legal watchdog the
supreme judicial council their march was
on the eighth anniversary of the
assassination of left-wing politician
chakrubali by gunmen who've not been
caught the anniversary is always an
emotional day for tunisians
a well-loved champion of human rights
and freedom bellaid's loss is still felt
deeply and his murder remains unsolved
his supporters demand the launch of a
murder investigation every year and call
for the prosecution of whoever was
responsible many tunisians say they've
lost faith in the justice system
today all political parties associations
and independence have come out to say
that corruption is over we all know
everyone knows that before july 25th
judicial appointments were based on
party affiliations and the supreme
judicial council was essentially built
on party affiliations
said says the supreme judicial council
is corrupt and is preventing politically
sensitive cases from being prosecuted
with the help of what he called hidden
powers
and it is your right as i said to
dissolve the superior council of the
judiciary where positions are sold
critics of the president say he's
targeting the judiciary in order to
consolidate national institutional power
they accuse him of a power grab
suspending parliament and dissolving
government last july
since then kai's side has ruled by
decree
overseeing all state institutions
including the judiciary which continues
to push back against his one-man rule
the conflict between the judges and the
president here seems far from over
eliza faltman al jazeera tunis